the northern ireland protocol bill
passed its second reading this evening
paving the way for the government to
scrap parts of the brexit agreement
let's find out more speak to our
political correspondent rob powell so
what happened rob
uh so yeah it passed its first hurdle in
the commons by a pretty comfortable
majority of 74 295 votes to 221 now no
conservative mps voted against um the
bill but quite a few did look like they
abstained so didn't vote for it or
against it people like theresa may uh
bob neal the justice committee chair and
simon hall the northern ireland
committee chair so that's essentially um
they didn't support the bill but they
did allow it through and that's i think
because this is at a relatively early
stage in its process through parliament
so one of those people that abstain bob
neal said he essentially wanted to see
whether it could be changed whether it
could be altered and how it turned out
but i think when you combine the number
of abstentions with some of the
criticism we heard in the chamber it
does indicate that maybe further down
the line when it comes back for a third
reading when it comes back for some of
those for where amendments and changes
could possibly be tabled there
potentially could be rebellions
ahead i think some of the most digging
criticism of course came from theresa
may who said she didn't think it was
legal she didn't think it would work and
she thought it would diminish the uk's
reputation
on the international stage so the next
uh what happens next with this bill is
it goes off and there's detailed
examination of it
before it comes back to the commons for
mps to debate it and potentially make
changes to it um again of course i think
part of the point of this bill was to
kind of up leverage on the eu so it may
well be that some of the tory critics
and where and some government ministers
may hope that the eu buckles and gives
in before it even comes back to the
commons